hey guys how's it going happy 2018 this
is my first unboxing video of the year
and I'm just gonna be completely honest
with you it's not gonna be that exciting
of an unboxing it's basically making a
video about a single iPhone case not
sponsored here's the case it says it's
holographic but I tweeted it and
everyone says that's not hollow
that is just iridescent I don't know I
mean what exactly is the difference
between a holographic and iridescent
because this is a fine line it is a very
fine line to cross so far my favorite
case is my iPhone 10 have been the basic
Apple cases I love the silicon cases so
much the two main colors that I've been
a huge fan of is this oh my gosh what's
it even call it it's like the pink
sandstone or pink stone pink sand pink
something something with sand it's
something with pink also the silicon
case in white I've also been a huge fan
of tech 21 cases I did a bunch of videos
with them earlier last year talking
about how durable the cases are and I'm
probably honestly gonna have to end up
putting this back on because I have
found myself dropping my iPhone a lot
lately and I'm not sure why I like I
will just be holding it and it basically
jumps out of my hand I know a lot of
people are concerned about the battery
issues that the older iPhones have an
Apple slowing down their phones what I'm
concerned about is I think that the
iPhone is now getting a mind of its own
because I think that it has been leaping
from my hands to its death on the ground
and I have zero control over it maybe
it's a me problem but I think that the
iPhone 10 I think it has a mind of its
own the next case that I've been using
is this case right here it is sort of a
love-hate relationship that I have with
this one of you guys tweeted me this is
such a scene if anyone can pull this off
it's you and so I was like you're right
to be honest with you I don't know if it
was that wise of a choice it's a cool
color but I feel like for every day it
just did not really match my personality
I know I'm so bright and sunny and
cheery you think this would be a
beautiful pick but no it's just okay so
from there I switch back to this and
then I was shopping tonight because I'm
going just es tomorrow or today
depending upon when you're watching this
I am probably driving up as we speak as
I speak as you watch I saw this case and
I said oh this looks super basic I have
to get it I also wanted to take the
opportunity of course we're going to CES
so why not open something so super
technologically advanced like an iPhone
case I mean make an entire video about
an iPhone case what's worse they can be
posted on YouTube I don't know posting a
dead body follows it too soon
maybe it is especially pieces to it do I
have to use this I hope I pushed record
it's been a while since I've filmed any
videos because I had so many videos prep
for the holidays it's a little
uncomfortable just coming back to this
desk in this office
I pushed regard we are set and now
there's a car backing up I've seen my
videos in the middle of the night for a
reason I'm getting used to making videos
again okay obviously I clearly need to
put this on so we're gonna put this on
first this is not look protective at all
so I have a really good feeling that my
phone is probably going to shatter at
CES so I'm going to bring my iPhone 8 as
a backup because this does not feel
protective at all I feel like if I drop
this this case is gonna shatter it's
just not a very high quality case but
I'll tell you what it looks really good
do we like this or is it so super basic
and stupid that it's not a good look I'm
confused now I'm having conflicting
feelings I don't want to tell you guys
to go out and buy this I also don't want
to tell you to not buy which was this
I'm a little indifferent to be honest
with you
he kind of looks cheap I was so excited
about this case when I bought it maybe
I'll return it I'm not sure Lucy what
are we even saying it's almost like I
forgot how to make youtube videos maybe
I did anyway look I do funky what do we
think I'll tell you one thing it's
better than the yellow it's pretty
flashy it feels heavy
I think I might go back to my tech 21
case let me know what you guys think in
the comments below and if I remember I
will put a pull here do you like the
psiphon case do you not like this iPhone
case well it G I'm going to CES I
skipped last year because I felt like I
don't really know I don't remember what
my reason was I know I definitely had
one I tried to cut back on traveling
since I got a dog which was about two
and a half years ago at this point so I
really now only travel if I actually
have to or if it's a link super fun or
if I can bring him along with me so I
figured see yes this year I was
definitely not gonna miss it so I look
forward to meeting some of you guys if
you're going to see us we'll let me know
I will be a bunch of random places so
I'll be tweeting out throughout the week
where I'll be usually I don't prep the
videos in advance so I usually don't
ever have any videos to post but for the
holidays it got really crazy all of a
sudden I ended up shooting a movie which
I don't think I told you guys about
that'll be out I believe sometime this
year at this point we filmed it in
Pittsburgh and it was so much fun I had
the best time especially because I was
back in my hometown filming a movie and
the movie is awesome it's soaked
I can't wait to tell you guys more about
that I had so many cooking videos that I
posted for you guys because I had shot
those in advanced editing at those so I
can really focus on shooting the movie
because doing things that are sort of
outside of my comfort zone I don't want
to have to worry about YouTube and
YouTube is a huge stress for me because
I do still edit all of my YouTube videos
by myself which is so crazy I know
everyone keeps telling me to get an
editor I have had so many requests if
people telling me just you know I can
edit for you it is a very difficult
thing to let go of for me it's very very
difficult and I don't think that I would
ever 100% let go of editing all of my
videos I feel like these types of things
where I'm sitting here talking to you
where it's a more intimate conversation
these things are always edit cooking
videos I feel like who can let it go a
little bit with those I think it's
pretty straightforward I'm just I'm
making something I'm usually screwing it
up and then you have the end result so
there's a clear formula for that but
what I'm doing vlogs I don't feel like
there's a formula I feel super attached
to the content because it's something
that I've shot and then I get to tell
the story how I want to tell it it's
crazy I don't know I'm not sure I've
just been trying to figure out this
whole YouTube space and what I want to
do in 2018 I would love to hear from you
guys what are your favorite type of
videos that I make let me know in the
comments what your favorite videos are
if you want to tweet me what your
favorite videos are as well feel free to
do that because I'm pretty much always
on Twitter non-stop at this point I'm
just rambling because I'm excited to
talk to you guys and I'm excited for
this year and excited to make really fun
things and I've got a bunch of fun
projects coming out and I don't know I'm
just excited I feel like this year
started off a little bit rough patch
here on YouTube and it really brought my
youtube spirits very very low it took my
motivation right out from under me it
took my inspiration just I don't know I
really just sat around for three days
and watched arrow I don't even know if
that was it good wise choice of my time
but I'll tell you what this show is
really good I finished flash over the
holidays I have just been getting in all
of the CW shows and also this is
completely completely sidetracked
because I've been watching so many
superhero shows I've decided that I want
to be a superhero I mean I've always
wanted to be one but I feel like that's
not realistic because there's not really
actually superheroes in real life I mean
maybe there are I don't know I've never
met one that starts falling off
god this shirt is great target going
back to superheroes
I don't read comics I've never really
read comics that I love the Marvel
Universe I love the movies I love the
Netflix shows and now that I'm getting
more into the DC shows like arrow and
flash one of the things that I was most
impressed about with guardians at the
galaxy for example was to me I knew
nothing about that franchise I knew
nothing about those characters and not a
lot of people did they basically took
these unknown characters this unknown
comic and brought it to life so what I
am interested to see is what is the next
thing that most of us normal people who
don't read comics what's the next thing
that we should be looking out for and is
there a character that I could
potentially play because that's what I'm
hoping for I need an unknown random
superhero character that is somewhere
hidden under comics got to dust it off a
little bit
and be like Justine this is you this is
you or do I just create my own that's
interesting maybe I could just do that
instead but what I love about an
already-existing character is there's an
entire universe already built and that
universe could potentially tie into
whether it's Marvel or DC it could
already potentially be tied into their
world I just wanna be a superhero is
that too much to ask maybe it is too
much to ask I'm not sure maybe had too
much caffeine maybe it's time for me to
end this video it's been a rough
beginning of the year guys but we're
back we're at CES now did anybody make
it to the end of this video cuz I'm not
even sure if I'm gonna be able to make
it to the end of this editing it in my
dog is sick Oh God
he pooped on my couch like I'm disgusted
I don't even want to show it to you oh
I'm gonna go I'm gonna edit this love
you guys I'll see you later
did I even make a bit of sense in this
video I don't think I did
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]